ray just announced his retirement and I
thought that maybe there was a chance he
was gonna play last year for Cleveland
decided not to but Ray joins us now I'm
curious the last phone call you got from
an NBA team the last phone call probably
probably Milwaukee's who sitting or
walking full circle
go back to Milwaukee yeah and what
what's so interesting about that is my
my freshman year I played with Rickey
Pierce in Rickey fears you know he was
one of the great Milwaukee Bucks of all
times and you know as his career took
full circle he ended back up in
Milwaukee and I kept thinking out of my
father you went all these places you
ended up right back in there walking and
he didn't play he was on the roster and
you know he I just remember him working
so hard like he was always out there
working on the game he's always shooting
and you know he didn't play a whole lot
and so I took that into consideration
like you know I'm older that he he was
then I'm all division now he was 38 then
and I'll say to myself out like it's
great to come to a team and really
provide you know anchor for them but am
I gonna be Rickey Pierce how he was back
in in 1996 I'm gonna be sitting on the
bench I'm working really hard just to
stay above board to just mostly young
people and trying to help them get
better um that was the unknown and again
like I said it was gonna involved me
moving my family out of where they are
now my kids are growing at a pretty good
rate in they're active in sports so I
just feel like now you know as I've
grown up you know my biggest and
greatest job and ultimately probably my
greatest legacy will be my children how
I laid them and what they ought to be
right and I'm envious of Dell curry
because he got two sons that are playing
professional basketball and they plan an
eye level so he needs done a great job
with those guys did you turn down a
chance to join the Cavs last year
um I I had I don't know
turned down is the right word I think
they certainly want to be to join them
and they they had every opportunity and
space from me on the roster I just you
know I only think everything and I try
to look at you know you know how I fit
in
yeah I probably wouldn't fit in well
with them but yeah it was it was all
about me what I wanted to do it without
ready to do it and you know what it was
getting involved and ultimately it was
you know again it was personal it was
just about me you know taking that that
leap and you know leaving leaving the
nest again and leaving the young the
young kids at home is not being a bad
it's hard enough now and I'm leaving I'm
so it reminded me of in 2007 I was
heavily heavily trying to accrue Reggie
Miller come and play in Boston and now
you know I was like you give us a great
chance when championship and you know I
was hoping I would love that play to
Reggie and you know he called me we had
several conversations and he also he
called me and said you know he's tried
and I you know I'm not I'm coming
I got a declined I got a pull out and so
I realized I was like you know when you
get to that age you realize your body
don't respond with them so I just come
off your name of that so I'm like I
don't I'm not gonna do it because I
don't have to and that's because you
can't do something doesn't mean you have
to do it he's Ray Allen now retired
joining us Dan Patrick show if I did a
retired three-point shooting contest
who's the favor who's the number one
seed the number one seed yeah the number
one seed and we're I'm assuming that
we're taking everybody based off of what
they did in the NBA and no no right now
right now Reggie and I 15 yeah yeah
right no I think I think I have a great
shot you know I'm I still play you know
quite a bit throughout the week so I
don't feel too different
you know about my body I think the
hardest thing for me is the recovery
like if you go through a season you know
you playing a game the next day how do
you feel how you recover so I don't I
don't think that I feel too different in
my shot feels pretty pretty solid they
got would be too far off Reggie said on
Tuesday I said Israel and a better
shooter than you and he goes I could
never admit that is anybody a better
shooter than you in NBA history of
course who I lost then you got me
concept and practice I lost you know I
will say you know in Miami LeBron was
probably one of the one of my greatest
competitors because LeBron always wanted
to you know he always wanted shooting
game he always wanted free-throw contest
now we didn't win often but he still
wanted the competition he still wanted
it because he knew it it pushed him in
animated game it took a game to another
level and I appreciate that one thing
about him because he was the one guy my
career that I did that but typically you
know the places I played like you know I
shot me Paul a lot and you know Paul
will beat me you know we will go back
and forth but Paul beat me it wasn't
nice you know it was so hard for me to
stay consistent you know because at my
jump shot is you know so based on you
know the list and if I didn't stay
consistent so that's why I drove me
crazy because I was always trying to
find ways to you know stay consistent
and so in the games I would leave a
manager but I was like back in force in
practice like I was trying to figure out
how it was my thinking time like trying
to figure out how do I get this and you
say before every game so I ran up and
get some buzz songs you know in my life
like guys like a shoot way better means
so my dad was the greatest better
shooting to me when I was growing up so
you know those things all these people
that I always know that were better than
me a shooter better me it always drove
me crazy so in my mind I always went to
the gym the next day cuz I was like I
know somebody better than me somebody's
shooting the ball way better me and when
we'd me I got make sure at least I'm
preparing had a chance to win
now that you're retired ray now we got
he got game too
and you're you're now a father and then
your son Moses Shuttlesworth is going to
college and now you're the dad
overseeing the recruitment the
one-and-done
I just wrote it for you Ray what do you
think don't forget about little Barry
Shuttlesworth no oh okay good WNBA yes
even beat yes you yeah yeah I will say
that there's so much storyline that
there can be told and then spike and I
have been talking about this over the
last you know year so about the things
that we we can talk about and you know
shine light on because one of the
interesting things about he got game was
that we we touched on everything that we
felt like as a recruited kid in high
school would deal with what they didn't
go through and so nowadays there's so
many more issues with social media you
know with this was black lives matter so
many things that are at the forefront of
you know America right now and what kids
have to navigate today I mean it's a
tough world I'm nervous to my boy so I
spend so much time trying to make sure
that they had their heads on straight
because once you step out of the door
there's no telling what can happen and
so I think we have an opportunity to be
able to put together your script where I
agree or really can entertain at the
same time educate he's still got game
could there's the title ray he still got
game yeah you can do you still got game
you could do he see got game like this
we can we can put it a little bit hey
dude did you settle things up with
Pierce I saw Paul Pierce talked recently
about when you left to Miami and sound
like Paul's still not over that well no
I read I read a little something about
it and I will say when I left when I
left Boston we were negotiating and you
know speaking you know on and off
Murdock he was
taking my age and I was talking with
Danny and you know when they had find
everybody else contracted out the last
person today that they came to and when
we didn't come to an agreement you know
they just kind of kept knocking me down
and lock me down and so I reached out
the kg and I told them I said it's not
looking good in a negotiation I don't
think they're they're going to you know
they're gonna extend my contract oh
they'll take care you know everything is
gonna work out and in addition so my one
regret in the process was I did not
reach out to Paul and tell him because
as I was speaking with KD it was real
time I got back to with more Danny and
speaking with Doc and you know it wasn't
happening so by the time like the hour
had unfolded
I was basically now a Miami Heat and you
know it was a foregone conclusion and so
you know the over the last of the years
you know I understand these guys didn't
want to talk to me because I wasn't on
the chain anymore and I was one of their
brothers like I understand like them
being upset with me but what I don't
understand is that it's business you
know we all signed contracts and
mouton's you know each one of us every
professional actually knows that when
you go into that that that room and you
gotta negotiate your contract like my
contract has nothing to do with the next
with my teammates contract and so I
can't criticize the deal that you have
to make because you got to do what you
think is best for your family and it
doesn't matter what you guys are signed
like now it's my turn and I gotta make
sure that you know my merits on the
court what I've done in the court
marriage what I get contractually so you
know I just had to just chalk it up and
said you guys don't they don't they
don't want to anymore you know I'm just
dead to them and so I did that wanted I
you know one thing I appreciated was
coming into Miami where I felt you know
the LA collaboration with you guys took
me in a they may
sure that I felt wanted and welcome well
have fun in retirement and let me know
if you are in the neighborhood to stop
by my mancave
I'd be more than happy to let you come
into my home court in a week maybe shoot
I'm always ready to shoot really so you
just let me know yeah just remember
that's my dojo it's a it's a home court
advantage they're ranked okay well you
know I don't I don't know if I win I
play golf with anybody I play basketball
me buddy and I don't care you know you
my kids you know I'd be so much on a
regular basis and I was like we play
knockout every day and I'm not listening
I'm winning and you guys come on in
learn to get better I like it
don't let him win man don't let him win
because it'll mean more to them when
they finally do beat you
exactly hey ray great to talk to you
Congrats on the decision and being at
home okay thank you Dad Ray Allen I'd
love to get ray stopped by the man cave
I could just watch somebody like that
shoot there's certain guys you can just
watch shoot and the ball was meant to be
in their hands and raise one of those
guys the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience